werden wir demnächst für unseren urlaub
bestraft die bundesregierung die hat da
zumindest pläne und will
lohnfortzahlungen streichen wenn
deutsche touristen in quarantäne müssen
nachdem sie aus einem risikogebiet
kommen gleichzeitig sollen die
quarantäne regeln verschärft werden
konkret sollen rückkehrer aus
risikogebieten dann auf jeden fall für
mindestens fünf tage in quarantäne
ob und wann das alles kommt das ist noch
unklar zurzeit diskutiert die regierung
da noch drüber blöd nur dass bald
herbstferien sind und dass urlauber
natürlich sehr verunsichert mir ist
jetzt zugeschaltet dirk anger erst der
hauptgeschäftsführer des deutschen
reiseverbandes guten abend häringer er
die erde frage was genau plant die
bundesregierung denn war jetzt ist es so
geplant dass reiserückkehrer die bewusst
in ein risikogebiet reisen dass es die
betrifft oder auch urlauber die jetzt in
den urlaub fahren und während des
aufenthalts dann das gebiet zum
risikogebiet wird die bundesregierung
ist im moment für eine große
verunsicherung der liste ist völlig
unerheblich ob sie bewusst in ein
risikogebiet fahren oder ob ein gebiet
das sie bereisen erst zum risikogebiet
wird in beiden fällen müssen sie bei der
rückkehr danach in eine fünftägige
zwangscharakter ne sie können sich davon
auch nicht befreien durch einen test und
das heißt hier wird mitten in den
herbstferien steht ja noch gar nicht
fest planen die bundesregierung mit
dieser regelung tatsächlich kommen will
eine große verunsicherung bei den
reisenden geführt und das ist weder
sachgerecht noch vernünftig angenommen
gerät herum trägt das jetzt durch
relativ schnell wird wohl nicht
passieren aber was befürchten sie
trotzdem
na ja also wir haben hier eine situation
wo wir eigentlich darüber reden müssen
was wäre der beste weg um zum
infektionsschutz zu kommen und aus sicht
der reiseunternehmen wäre der beste weg
zum infektionsschutz eine vernünftige
test strategie die risikobasierte ist
wenn man sich die ergebnisse der reise
rücken
der test anschaut die wir seit anfang
august haben dann wissen wir sehr genau
ausrichten starten und reisezielen
eigentlich die infektionen zurück kommen
nach deutschland an der spitze liegt
beispielsweise das kosovo aber auch
länder wie beispielsweise bosnien oder
montenegro
das sind länder aus den offensichtlich
durch falsches verhalten ein einschnitt
risiko besteht sind übrigens keine
klassischen urlaubsziele sondern hier
finden überwiegend familien und thorn
dass besucher statt
und wenn man sich hier konzentrieren
würde auf die staaten aus denen diese
infektion kommen dann würde man das
anstellt risiko sehr stark minimieren
das wäre auch unsere erwartung an herrn
sparen wir haben vor einigen wochen ein
test konzept vorgeschlagen mit dem man
diese risiken deutlich minimieren könnte
stattdessen anwendung beispielsweise ein
verbot auf die kanaren zu reißen es gibt
noch eine einzige insel auf den kanaren
von den sieben ds dort bei denen im
moment eine etwas höhere infektionsrate
ist trotzdem darf keine einzige bereist
werden
das ist nicht besonders schlau
schließlich haben wir ja auch keine
quarantäne regelung wenn man aus einem
bayerischen hotspot wo man urlaub
gemacht hat zurück nach hause fährt da
ist also einiges zu erklären durch den
bundesgesundheitsminister
das waren jetzt sehr sehr viele
informationen ihrerseits versuchen wir
das noch mal ein bisschen zu
konkretisieren was genau fordern sie
oder wo sagen sie dass es für uns für
die tourismusbranche ein kompromiss also
wir wollen risiken vermeiden auf
einschlägigen dazu brauchen wir tests
die bundesregierung hat zunächst test
eingeführt anfang august dann hat sie
gesagt wir haben aber gar nicht die
kapazitäten wenige wochen später dass
wir so einen zick zack kurs
nach unseren erkenntnissen stimmt das
auch nicht diese test kapazitäten sind
sehr wohl daran können zur verfügung
gestellt werden und wir glauben dass
testen besser ist als quarantäne
es gibt keinen vernünftigen grund leute
fünf tage weg zu sterben
das sparen muss ich daran erinnern dass
bundesgesundheitsminister und nicht
bundes reise veränderungs mindest mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich jedes nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren